the end
of an era from today commercial coal
mining in england is effectively over
the bradley mine in county durham has
operated for almost 200 years
but now the open cast pit that produces
150
000 tons of coal a year will close
i'm devastated i'm absolutely devastated
that it's coming to a close this will be
the last coal mine that i'll probably
ever work on
that will be it say what now
i haven't got a clue my partner's family
are in it
they've been in it for 30 years i'm
obviously coming with late
my father like i say work with british
steel that industry's gone um
it's it's awful i think that there's
there's british lads there
that can do the job we've got all the
all the machinery
got all the training probably more
qualified than a lot of the rest of the
world
but we've had it all taken away from us
there are still
a handful of small mines like this
operating in scotland and wales
but their days too are numbered
the coal industry in england has been in
decline for years
the minor strikes and the pitched
battles over pit closures in the 1980s
couldn't save it and it's faced a slow
and painful death ever since
the last deep mine at kellingly in north
yorkshire closed five years ago
since then the only home produced coal
has come from open cast mines like
bradley
there is still coal here in concert but
owners banks group
says it's only commercially viable if
they can extend their operation
environmental campaigners fought hard
against those plans
and won the truth is we can't carry on
serving the purpose of profit at the
price of our lives
but sort of we have to make this
transition and we have to do all that we
can because our lives
in this planet is at stake economic
advances
matter for nothing on a dead planet
the company that mines this coal also
operates 10
onshore wind farms it argues that as
long as there is a need for it
the environmental cost of importing coal
is far greater
than that of producing it here we
support the move to a cleaner climate
that
we are not climate change deniers we
understand that
but at the minute and for the short to
medium term we need call
that's why we need to make mine in the
call here in county durham
and in northumberland in newcastle upon
time for our forward program sites
it makes economic and environmental
sense to do just that
the company still hopes to revive
english mining it's waiting for a
delayed government decision on plans for
a site near newcastle
but with britain aiming for coal-free
electricity production
by 2025 and with demand consistently
falling
this may well be the last coal that
england
ever produces fraser moored sky news
concert